[Musique]
Bonsoir Pierre Lelouche. Bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Et bien euh je
m'appelle Pierre Lelouche. Euh j'ai été
levé dans ce quartier ici même
longtemps. Euh que dire ? Que je suis
vieux malheureusement 73 ans, que ces
années sont passées très très vite et
que je continue à travailler plein pot
sur les questions internationales qui
ont été la grande passion de ma vie
quoi. J'ai toujours été passionné par
l'histoire des peuples, par les raisons
pour lesquelles les gens s'entretuaient.
En fait, c'est une espèce de quête du
pourquoi du comment les les pays se font
la guerre.
Vous avez été ministre ?
H
vous avez été président de l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN.
Oui.
Ministre,
j'ai été j'ai été universitaire, j'étais
avocat, j'ai décliné et et éditorialiste
et je ce que je continue à faire
d'ailleurs, je continue à écrire
beaucoup. J'ai décliné
cette curiosité pour les affaires
internationales à peu près sous toutes
les formes possibles
professionnellement,
sauf malheureusement à être milliardaire
comme Elan Musk va lancer de très
grandes sociétés comme G femme. Eux ils
sont ils ont dominé le monde d'une autre
façon. Moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
monde des idées.
On est très content de vous recevoir ce
soir pour plein de raisons parce que
vous avez connu Marc Ulman, Pierre Asner
parce que vous avez été journaliste,
parce que vous êtes spécialisé en droit
en plus d'être journaliste.
Ma première question concernant la
Russie et l'Ukraine, pourquoi on l'a pas
vu venir ? Comment ça ça a germé ? Où on
en est et où ça va nous emmener ? Alors,
je viens de sortir un livre qui
qui s'appelle engrenage aux édition
qui s'appelle engrenage aux éditions
Odil Jacob 23,9.
Ce sous titre, c'est engrenage de la la
guerre d'Ukraine et le basculement du
monde. Parce que dans l'affaire de
l'Ukraine, il y a l'Ukraine et puis il y
a le l'impact que ça a sur la planète
toute entière. Donc commençons par la
question que vous posez à savoir euh les
relations entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
et pourquoi on a rien voulu voir ou vu
voir venir cette affaire. Moi, je
considère que cette guerre, c'est
l'histoire d'une d'une guerre annoncée.
En fait, c'est la guerre de sécession
d'Ukraine par rapport à la Russie. C'est
une très vieille histoire.
Euh les Russes considèrent que leur
berceau de naissance, confirmé
d'ailleurs par François Mitteran qui l'a
dit lui-même à Kief, leur berceau c'est
Kief. Les Russes disent ça, les
Ukrainiens pas du tout. Mais enfin,
autrement dit, les le lien entre ces
deux peuples slaves est extrêmement
fort. Euh a perduré au fil de euh 600
ans d'occupation polonaise et
lithuienne, 300 ans de domination russe,
beaucoup de de mariages croisés,
beaucoup de rencontres au cours de ces
siècles. Mais c'est c'est pas ça dont je
veux parler. Dans la période moderne,
la question de l'Ukraine s'est posée
plusieurs fois.
Elle s'est posée
dès la fin de la Première Guerre
mondiale. Une délégation ukrainienne est
d'ailleurs venue a été d'ailleurs dirigé
par un juif ukrainien qui s'appelait
Margolis et qui a essayé de faire
reconnaître son pays par les vainqueurs
de 1918. En fait, personne n'en voulait.
Ni les vainqueurs, ni les vaincus
l'entente, ni les bolcheviques, ni les
russes blancs. Personne ne voulait d'un
état ukrainien. à l'époque et il
ça a été une phase extrêmement violente
entre 1917 la révolution russe et 1920
22 il y a eu plein de gouvernements
successifs à Kiev
et l'Ukraine n'a jamais été
indépendante. a été absorbé et d'abord
coupé en morceau entre la Pologne, la
Tchécoslovaquie, la Russie et cetera
jusque jusqu'à l'opération Barbarosa
1941 à l'arrivée des Allemands. Et là,
les nationalistes allemands euh pardon
ukrainien s'allent avec les Allemands
pour essayer de de sortir les
soviétiques ukrainien. Il y a eu euh là
aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de morts,
beaucoup de massacres et les Russes ont
utilisé la résistance ukrainienne puis
l'ont jeté. Ils ont mis en prison tous
les chefs tous les chefs de de l'armée
ukrainienne indépendante de l'époque.
Donc ça constamment été un jeu de
bascule depuis le 17e siècle entre les
Ukrainiens. À chaque fois pour se
débarrasser des Russes, on s'aliait avec
l'État d'à côté, tantôt la Suède, tantôt
l'Allemagne et aujourd'hui c'est les
États-Unis et l'Union européenne. Et
donc cette histoire euh qui est très
compliquée en réalité parce que si on
lit les auteurs russes euh h
c'est
très compliqué de dire qu'il y avait euh
une coupure entre les deux les on
appelait ça à l'époque au 19e siècle les
grands russiens et les petits russiens.
Les deux les deux peuples étaient mêlés
et toute la partie est le Donbas qui est
revendiqué aujourd'hui par Poutine a été
colonisée par les Russes. Il y avait
personne. C'était des steps avec
quelques tatars mais la la Crimée était
turque au départ avant d'être prise par
Catherine I et toute la partie du Dbas a
été conquise par des Russes mais il y
avait aussi des Grecs, il y avait
Bulgares, toutes sortes de gens dans
cette partie est de l'Ukraine. En
revanche à l'ouest, du côté de Le Wolf,
il vivent avant Linberg. Là, il y a des
des Ukrainiens tournés vers l'Occident
et vers l'Allemagne.
Et il n'aimait pas non plus les
Polonais. Il y a eu beaucoup de
massacres de Polonais. Les juifs
naturellement ont été à chaque fois
massacrés fit à mesure. Euh
mais les gens de l'Ouest détestent les
Russes. C'est un des une des une des
explications. Bon arrive bon Stalin fait
l'Ukraine moderne et que les frontières
actuelles, enfin les frontières de
l'Ukraine tellères
tracées par Stalin en 45. Donc on
récupère des morceaux qui étaient à
l'ouest et on met tout ça ensemble, sauf
la Crimée qui rejoindra l'Ukraine
soviétique par un cadeau de
Kchov qui qui était né à la frontière
entre l'Ukraine et et la Russie. Krvfit
cadeau de l'Ukraine de la Crimée à
l'Ukraine en 54 ou en 56. 54 je crois.
56.
Et donc on a les frontières de l'Ukraine
d'indépendance.
Bon euh
pourquoi on l'a pas vu venir ?
Alors attendez, attendez. 91,
l'Union Soviétique est pliée, le mur de
Berlin tombe et on va vers
l'indépendance
de toutes les Républiques ex-soviétiques
dont l'Ukraine qui fait un un son
référendum en décembre 1991. Quelques
semaines avant, George Push père va à
Kiev et devant le les les
le comité central
qui est vient l'époque, il dit aux
Ukrainiens les États-Unis ne
soutiendront pas l'indépendance de
l'Ukraine et ne soutiendront pas la
haine ethnique. La haine ethnique
déjà à l'époque.
Ouais. et et Mitteran lui-même euh à
Kiev toujours pendant la période
soviétique avec Gorbatchov explique que
le berceau de la Russie c'est Kief. Donc
pour les dirigeants occidentaux, il
n'est pas du tout question de de de
faire divorcer ces deux peuples ou de
couper de
les les les Russes les Boris Helsin
essayaient naturellement de conserver.
Ils avaient compris que l'Europe de
l'Est était partie, mais ils voulaient
conserver les régions qui étaient les
plus proches de la Russie. Et
Solgenitzin lui-même avait écrit, je le
cite dans mon livre d'ailleurs, des
passages où où il dit euh
ils ont le droit de partir, de toute
façon, ils sont pas russes.
Les Ukrainiens, s'ils veulent vraiment
partir, ils peuvent partir sauf la
partie qui est russe, ce qu'il appelle
la Novorcia. La Novorcia, c'est l'idée
de de Poutine aussi. de conserver la la
zone qui est historiquement à leurs yeux
russes. Alors, je rentre pas là-dedans,
mais c'est dire l'intimité entre les
deux peuples et au moment où l'Ukraine
devient indépendante se pose la question
de savoir ce que devient cette zone
comprise entre l'Allemagne et la Russie.
Encore une fois, la question n'avait pas
été traitée à la fin de la Première
Guerre mondiale, ni à la fin de la
Seconde puisque Staline avait tout
englobé. cette fois-ci, elle va se
poser.
Les Européens de l'Est n'ont qu'un
souci, c'est de raller l'Occident le
plus vite possible, l'Union européenne
et surtout l'OTAN pour se protéger des
Russes. Euh et les Ukrainiens, bah ils
aimeraient bien aussi se détacher mais
en fait personne n'en veut. Et la
question de savoir ce que va devenir
l'Ukraine,
personne en réalité la pose.
Et
on va avoir
à Kief
des gouvernements
absolument corrompus comme à Moscou,
comme ailleurs. Euh une chute drastique
du de la production du PIB ukrainien
pendant cette période, l'émigration de 7
millions de personnes. Bref, l'Ukraine
va mal. Elle essaie de se tourner vers
l'Europe mais l'Europe n'a pas vraiment
de solution.
Arrive en 2003 la première révolution
orange. Moi, j'y étais le premier Maidan
en 20032004 avec l'élection de de
Yushenko.
Il y avait il y avait pas encore George
McCain sur zone.
John McCain c'était un de mes gros amis,
le sénateur Mc bien sûr, il s'occupait
c'était
là-bas.
Ah bah il y a les fondations américaines
qui essayaient naturellement. Il y a une
grosse diaspora polonaise et ukrainienne
aux États-Unis et surtout au Canada. Et
donc les Américains, il y a une histoire
aussi assez son parce que beaucoup de
beaucoup d'anciens nazis se sont
planqués
au Canada après guerre. Donc il a dit
beaucoup de choses dans les archives
américaines qu'il faudrait les voir mais
c'était période pas très très claire
quoi. Mais mais
la complexité de cette affaire
ukrainienne, elle a été aggravée par la
lutte d'influence entre les deux empires
avec Mcenland qui expliqu ça c'est après
après. Mais il y avait une lutte
d'influence naturellement
l'affaire ukrainienne est devenue
vraiment difficile à partir du moment où
les relations Amériques Russie se sont
tendues dans les années 90. Mais il y a
eu une période immédiatement après la
fin de la guerre froide. Je sais puisque
j'avais amené Chirak à Moscou à ce
moment-là au moment de de la révolution
en 91, il y a eu une période où
à Moscou on on était plutôt favorable à
sortir de la dictature et à se
réconcilier avec l'Occident. Et ils
attendaient beaucoup de l'Occident. Sauf
que l'Occident était pas trop au
rendez-vous pour mettre de l'argent,
pour les aider à faire cette transition.
Et petit à petit, les les voies ont
divergé à nouveau. Et donc l'Ukraine,
elle a été prise dans cette tenaille
d'opposition impériale entre l'Amérique
et la Russie euh en en étant mal dirigé,
en servant de conduit au gaz russes qui
venaient à provisionner l'Europe. Donc
il y a des enjeux extrêmement forts.
Voilà pourquoi on n pas voulu venir
parce que parce que comme le dit un des
grands historiens de l'Ukraine
avant 2013
Oui, c'était c'était le comment dire le
point blanc dans la mémoire des
Européens. Pour les Européens, l'Ukraine
n'existait pas, c'était une partie de la
Russie et voilà, on avait des images un
peu romantiques des tatars
mais mais personne s'est s'est posé la
question de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
allait faire de cet état qui était en
permanence colonisé, divisé. C'est une
terre sans sans problème, je veux dire
sans sans relief. Donc c'est une terre
de passage des empires. C'est comme
Timothy Sneider appelle ça les terres de
sang. Il y a il y a tout le monde est
mort. Il y a des millions et des
millions de morts à commencé par les
Juifs mais aussi des Polonais, les
Ukrainiens. Il y a eu la grande famine
des années 20, l'Olod de mort qui a tué
4 millions d'Ukrainiens au moins sur
ordre de Staline. Donc c'est une c'est
une terre de sang.
Et aujourd'hui, on est dans une guerre
qui est incroyablement
violente. 1 million de victimes quand
même, personne ne parle mais c'est
colossal. Il y a il y a
côté russe et côté ukrainien mélangé.
Il y a 250000 morts côté russes, 150000
côté ukrainien à peu près des centaines
de milliers de blessés. C'est une guerre
énorme. On parla tout à l'heure des des
leçons qu'on peut en tirer sur le plan
militaire. Mais pourquoi on a rien vu
venir ? Parce que ça n'existait pas dans
le mental des Européens. ni des
Américains euh tandis que les les Russes
eux considèrent que c'est à eux quoi.
C'est le le le problème, il est là si
vous voulez. Et quand la guerre est
arrivée, quand l'invasion est arrivée,
en 2014, on avait semblant de rien voir
pour la pour la Crimée et avec des
petites sanctions, des choses comme ça,
mais on est revenu business as usual. En
2022, c'était difficile à faire puisque
la grande surprise stratégique de la
guerre de 2022, c'est la résistance
ukrainienne.
Tout le monde pensait que ça allait être
plié en 3 jours.
C'est c'est la résistance ukrainienne ou
si c'est le fait que Poutine a envoyé
des colonnes de char à la fleur au fusil
où ils sont fait démonter. Euh euh
c'est ça la surprise stratégique, c'est
que ces colonnes de char devaient faire
comme en Tchécoslovaquie, devaiit
rentrer, renverser le pouvoir en
quelques jours, c'était l'affaire était
pliée en 3 jours. C'était l'opinion
aussi des Américains.
J'ai j'ai une question à vous posiez.
Quand vous étiez ministre, secrétaire
d'État au commerce extérieur,
imaginez-vous, est-ce que notre
secrétaire d'État au commerce extérieur
ou notre ministre de l'économie
aurait-il pu recevoir une note des
services de renseignement pour lui dire
ça va pas être bon pour notre commerce
extérieur, les prévisions pour notre
commerce avec la guerre, ça va être
compliqué. Nos afflu énergétiques n'ont
même pas été évolués. On sait même pas
comment router les choses. Est-ce que
vous pensez que recevoir ce type de note
quand on est au ministère, ça permet
d'éviter ensuite d'éviter des tweets du
genre on va mettre l'économie russe à
genou ?
Ouais. Non, je je sais pas répondre à
cette question. Sauf pour vous dire que
quand moi j'étais au manett de ces
ministères dans les dans les années
avant 2012, donc avant la Crimée,
il y avait une relation de travail très
très utile avec les Russes. Euh
on avait des le le site de nos fusées en
Guyane était ouvert. On avait une
coopération avec les Russes. On lançait
des fusées russes depuis la Guyane.
C'est l'époque où on vendait des
des portes hélicoptères, des des avions,
des bateaux de débarquement mistral aux
russes en 2012 quand Poutine vient
en signe en signe les bateaux. C'est
l'époque où l'Allemagne se drogue
complètement au gaz russe, construit euh
Nordstream 1 puis Nordstream 2, donc
Norstream 2 après la Crimée. Donc il y
avait euh voulez l'une des difficultés
dans toute cette affaire, c'est qu'il y
a un énorme potentiel de relation
économique entre l'Europe et la Russie.
La Russie est pleine de matières
premières, notamment de gaz, de pétrole,
agriculture et autar de titane
et ils ont besoin de technologie. Donc,
il y avait énormément de business entre
l'Europe et la Russie. Euh, les
Allemands bien sûr, mais nous aussi.
Plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'investissements intérieurs de la
Russie. Donc il y avait pas vraiment le
désir de tout casser. Euh le problème
c'est que parallèlement les relations
politiques avec l'Occident se sont de
plus en plus tendues.
Euh Poutine arrive au pouvoir en 99
et puis il y a les guerres de Téchenie.
Et au sortir de tout cela, après euh
rappelez-vous en 2001, au moment de la
de l'Afghanistan, les Russes sont les
premiers à vouloir aider les Américains.
Moi, j'étais en charge d'Afghanistan
pendant un an. On transitait par la
Russie. Nos soldats passaient par la
Russie pour aller en Afghanistan. Et
quand on a plié bagage, on est repassé
par la Russie. Donc il y avait une vraie
coopération y compris sur l'Afghanistan
avec la Russie. Donc c'est c'était une
époque où les gens se parlaient mais euh
il y a eu il y a eu tous les événements
autour, il y a eu la Libye, il y a eu
les Balcans et petit à petit les Russes
ont commencé à dire "Bon, on n'est pas
pris au sérieux. C'est l'époque où Obama
appelait la Russie une
puissance moyenne
où John McCain euh mon collègue et ami
sénateur américain appelé la Russie une
grosse station d'essence avec des bombes
atomiques.
Donc les Russes n'aient pas trop ça
quoi. Et euh je me souviens d'une
conversation avec Yevgeni Primakov qui
voulait être président qui a été en fait
remplacé si j'ose dire par Poutine.
Primakov connaissait parfaitement la
politique étrangère, l'Europe, le
proche-orient. C'est un expert du monde
arabe et il dirigeait l'ImO à l'époque
où je parlais avec lui, l'Institut russe
des affaires internationales et il était
l'inventeur du concept de du du pivot
eurasiatique de la Russie. Son truc
c'était de dire bon si les Américains ne
nous respectent pas et si après avoir
perdu le pact de Varsovie le comc faut
voir ce que c'est que la Russie comment
elle a fondu à la fin de la guerre
froide. C'est un choc terrible d'avoir
perdu tout le glacier occidental
euh de voir toutes ces anciens pays
d'Europe centrale rejoindre à toute
vitesse l'OTAN et donc pour eux c'était
un choc profond. euh des occidentaux qui
faisaient semblant de de s'intéresser à
la Russie mais en fait était passé déjà
autre chose. Bah il s'intéresse
et Yevgeni Premakov son truc c'était de
dire puisque
puisque euh l'Amérique veut pas
s'intéresser à nous, qu'on a pas notre
place à égalité avec l'Amérique, c'est
toujours le le l'obsession des Russes.
Bah, dans ce cas-là, moi je bascule à
une autre partie de mon passé,
c'est-à-dire le pivot eurasiatique et je
fais avec la Chine, le pays le plus
puiss le plus grand du monde, plus
peuplé
et je fais avec l'Iran le pays musulman
le plus puissant. Et et l'idée c'était
de construire une stratégie de
remplacement avec cette triade russe,
Russie, Chine, Iran. Et c'est cette
triade qu'on va voir renaître après 2022
au moment de la guerre de de d'Ukraine.
Et on on voit là se dresser
face à nous
le début d'un monde post-occidental
et dirigé par la Chine et la Russie avec
eux deux autres pays parfaitement
toxiques, l'Iran et la Corée du Nord. et
derrière ce que les Russes appellent la
majorité du monde, c'est-à-dire le sud
global. Donc dans mon livre, je raconte
si vous voulez la jeunesse de cette
affaire ukrainienne avec la la
problématique de qui contrôle quoi au
centre de l'Europe. C'est la question
qui va se poser dès qu'on va parler de
négociation de paix, on va y revenir.
Donc c'est la première question, c'est
que devient cette ce pays tampon entre
l'Allemagne et la Russie qui fait l'obj
l'objet aujourd'hui d'une guerre par
procuration non déclarée entre l'OTAN et
la Russie parce que c'est quand même ça
entre
les États-Unis et la Chine ?
Alors, il y a ce problème là et le
second problème c'est quelles sont les
conséquences de ça sur le reste du monde
avec l'apparition, je vous dis les
quatre ce que j'appelle les quatre
cavaliers de l'apocalypse, les Chinois,
les Russes, les Nord-Coréens et les
Iraniens. Et on voit bien aujourd'hui
que la guerre a déjà métastasé au
Proche- Orient puis qu'elle elle peut le
faire aussi en en Orient puisque vous
avez vu que des soldats nord-coréens, on
dit que les soldats coréens sont en
train d'arriver sur le front face à
l'Ukraine. Donc
il y a eu des mantiis des coré des des n
d' nord coréen il y a pas longtemps.
Mais peut-on leur faire confiance ?
juste avant qu'on passe à 2022
après la Crimée, c'estàd l'invasion, du
moins le les petits soldats verts russes
qui ont attrapé la Crimé.
Ça c en 14 2014.
2014, tout à fait. Donc à partir de
2014, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Est-ce
que on n pas vu un peu trop McCain sur
place qui excitait un peu tout le monde,
les révolutions colorées, j'en passé des
meilleurs, Victoria Nuland qui excitait
un petit peu tout le monde. La question
que je me pose, c'est les Américains ont
quel intérêt
à mettre un conflit ouvert au sein même
de l'Europe ?
Vous savez quoi ? Les Américains après
s'intéressent à peine à l'Ukraine. Il y
a pas de stratégie en Ukraine. Euh il y
a très peu d'armes
après le début de la guerre dans le
Donbas. Ils mettent pas beaucoup
d'armes. C'est Blincen. Alors à l'époque
on a Biden comme vice-président et
Blinken comme le conseiller la sécurité
de de Biden. Et la question se pose
est-ce que les Américains doivent donner
des armes aux Ukrainiens ? Et la réponse
est non. Mais avant de leur donner des
armes, est-ce qu'il y avait pas une
militarisation de de l'intellect du
peuple ukrainien ?
Non, le peuple ukrainien jusqu'à 2010
2011, je le dis dans mon livre, je sors
les les sondages, il est divisé. La
partie ouest, elle est proato, pro
autant, pro la partie est, elle rêve
plutôt d'être le pont entre les deux.
Elle a pas nécessairement envie d'une
d'une guerre ou d'un passage en
Occident. C'est et et les Américains,
les Européens sont d'abord obsédés par
les liens avec la Russie et les
Allemands surtout le gaz. Après la
Crimée, ils construisent Nordstream 2
quand même que Angela Merkel voudra
maintenir jusqu'à la dernière minute
avant même l'invasion. Elle s'accrochait
encore à ce tuyau de gaz. Quant à nous,
on vendait des bateaux
et ceris sur le gâteau, on désarmait le
le faut bien comprendre une chose, c'est
que c'est là aussi que cette guerre de
d'Ukraine est est un moment tournant
dans l'histoire du monde. C'est que il y
a 30 ans, on avait un tournant. Le
tournant d'il y a 30 ans, c'était on va
vers la démocratie, on a gagné la guerre
froide, on va vers la démocratie, va y
avoir la mondialisation, c'est le moment
de la paix éternelle. Et le rêve c'était
que les peuples avec la mondialisation
deviendraient des peuples de
consommateurs interchangeables. Que
c'est le succès de la civilisation
occidentale. C'était la la thèse un peu
naïve de de Fukuyama à l'époque qui
l'emportait. On était dans on voyait des
décennies de paix. Ce qui est en train
de basculer aujourd'hui avec la guerre
d'Ukraine et les et les métastases que
l'on voit au Orient, en Orient et
cetera, c'est la conscience que la
violence est devenue quotidienne,
décomplexée, que dans un continent
bourré d'armes nucléaires comme
l'Europe, on peut faire une guerre de
hausse intensité qui depuis 3 ans,
c'était impensable pour des gens comme
Pierre Asner et autres ou moi qui avait
travaillé sur les questions de
dissuasion. La crise de Cuba avait duré
13 jours et tout le monde était accroché
au rideau en craignant une guerre une
guerre nucléaire alors qu' il y avait
que un blocus naval de 13 jours à
l'issue duquel d'ailleurs on a retiré
les armes nucléaires russes de Cuba et
les armes américaines de Turquie. Mais
là, on est on va vers la 3e année de
guerre avec encore une fois un million
de de victimes. Tout ça dans une zone où
il y a quand même deux il y a il y a
quatre puissances nucléaires directement
engagées. Russie enfin directement
directement ou indirectement par des
livraisons d'armes. Les Américains, les
Anglais, les Français puis en face les
Russes et
du soutien technique et de de
l'intelligence. Juste une question
concernant les différents accords qui
avaient été signés après la Crimée. Il y
a eu les accords de Budapest, il y a eu
les accords de
alors alors non pas tout mélangé. Euh ce
qui s'est passé, il y a une première
série d'accords au moment où tout allait
bien, c'estàd années 90 où Américains et
Russes s'embrassaient sur la bouche, il
y avait pas de problème. Et qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait ? On a aidé les Russes à
récupérer les armes nucléaires qui
étaient en Ukraine. Tenez-vous bien, au
moment de l'indépendance de l'Ukraine,
en 91, il y avait 5000 armes nucléaires
en Ukraine. Et en Ukraine, en en 91,
l'Ukraine était la 3è puissance
nucléaire au monde derrière les
États-Unis et la Russie. Les Russes
naturellement l'entendaient pas ainsi,
voulaient récupérer leur leur bombe
atomique. Et les Américains aussi parce
que les Américains, ils étaient obsédés
par l'idée que ces armes puissent se
retrouver dans les mains de terroristes.
Et comme ils avaient noté que les
Ukrainiens n'hésitaient pas à vendre des
armes un peu partout et notamment dans
des pays pas très net.
Vendre, c'est un bien grand mot.
Si si, il y avait l'industrie
l'industrie ukrainienne a commencé à
vendre des trucs au Prochrient et
autres. Donc les les Américains étaient
tétanisés à l'idée que qu'il y ait des
bombes qui puissent passer dans des pays
pas très pas très catholique entre
guillemets. Et donc le résultat c'était
de conclure un accord avec les Russes
pour rapatrier cela. Et donc on a appelé
ça le mémorandum de Budapest. On a forcé
trois pays de l'exion soviétique, le
Kazakhstan, euh la Biélorussie et
l'Ukraine, à renoncer aux armes
nucléaires, d'accord ? À signer le
traité de nombre prolifération en
échange de garantie de sécurité. Euh
c'est-à-dire que les pays du les cinq
membres du conseil de sécurité devaient
en cas d'agression venir au secours du
du de l'Ukraine agressée. Je publie dans
mon livre en annexe la garantie
française qui fait 5 lignes signé
François Mitteran. Euh et c'est
pathétique. Ça veut dire que personne
n'avait l'intention de venir au secours
de l'Ukraine. En réalité, ce qu'on
voulait c'était s'assurer que les armes
nucléaires ne finissent pas entre de
mauvaises mains. Ça c'était les années
90. D'accord. Donc
ensuite ensuite l'Ukraine reste sous le
contrôle à peu près des Russes sur le
plan stratégique. Les elle essaie de
s'ouvrir vers l'Union européenne et
l'OTAN mais en fait personne n'a envie
de la prendre dans le temps et personne
Russe surtout pas. Non, mais même du
côté occidental la question il y il y
avait un comité autant Ukraine, il y
avait un comité autant Russie mais tout
le monde faisait attention de ne pas de
pas envenimer les choses. Nous encore
une fois du côté occidental,
notre problème c'était de faire du
business avec la Russie derrière
l'Allemagne. l'Allemagne qui en plus se
dénucléaris
pour des raisons de politique
intérieure, donc à fond vers le gaz
russe.
L'équilibre de l'Allemagne dans
l'après-gerre froide, c'est trois choses
: sécurité américaine, exportation
chinoise et pour exportation chinoise,
gaz russe. C'était ça la l'équation
allemande. Et nous, on était on suivait
tout le monde suivait ça. On en a
profité pour désarmer massivement, vous
savoir qu'on se retrouve
dividend de la paix et ainsi de suite.
Revenons, revenons, revenons à Angela
Merkel et François Hollande qui ont
confessé que c'était les accords de
Munich
de Minsk
de Minsk, pardon, excusez-moi.
Donc ça c'est après la Crimée.
Comment ça
confessé ? Quoi
après la Crimée ? Bon, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé au moment de la Crimée ? Il
se passe que
ça a commencé un peu par hasard. Les les
Européens étaient en négociation pour
une zone de libre échange d'accord
économique avec l'Ukraine. Les Russes ne
voulaient pas en entendre parler et il
faisaient pression sur le président à
l'époque prousse Yanukovic pour qu'il
signe pas avec les Européens. Mais les
Européens c'était la troica. C'était pas
une direction politique, il y avait pas
une décision majeure de des leaders
européens de l'époque d'aller prendre
l'Ukraine sous notre aelle. Il y avait
une discussion bureaucratique comme
d'habitude à Bruxelles. On envoie la
troica pour négocier un accord avec
c'était dans le cadre de la politique
dit de voisinage. Donc on on essaie de
mettre en place un accord de libre
échange mais les Russes n'en veulent
pas. Les Russes préviennent que
si l'Ukraine va vers le temps, il y aura
une guerre. Ça c'était Poutine l'avait
déjà dit en 2008 lors du sommet de Bucha
c'est une histoire compliquée, je
reviens en arrière. Il faut comprendre
que à partir des années 2000, Poutine
durcit par rapport à la à l'Ukraine. Il
commence à dire que ils ne veulent plus
de la domination américaine sur les
affaires du monde. Il prononce un
discours de ce de ce type à Munich en
2007, en 2008 et à Bucarest.
Le président de l'époque, c'est George
W. Le fils Bush qui à l'inverse de son
père veut terminer son mandat avec
l'inclusion de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN. À
ce moment-là, Merkel et Sarco disent
"Non, si vous faites ça, il y aura la
guerre." Et donc, on ne fait pas rentrer
l'Ukraine dans le temps à ce moment-là.
Il y a pas d'invitation mais il y a un
communiqué qui dit "Ils ont la l'Ukraine
et la Géorgie ont vocation à rentrer
dans le temps." Pour les Russes, c'était
une déclaration
belligérance en réalité. Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé 4 mois plus tard ? Bah 4
mois plus tard, il y a eu la guerre de
Geéorgie et Sarkozy pendant l'été va
là-bas en Geéorgie, je connais bien,
pour stopper les choses. Donc il y avait
ce problème là dans le background si je
dire arrive
2013, les Européens offrent un accord de
coopération commerciale avec l'Ukraine.
Poutine dit non. Et moi je vois Poutine
à ce moment-là en tête à tête. J'ai
accompagné François Fill en septembre
2013 au moment de ces manœuvres entre
les Européens et les Russes qui
faisaient tout tout le monde faisait
pression sur le gouvernement ukrainien
et Poutine me dit "Moi, je laisserai
jamais passer l'Ukraine à l'ouest, ça
fait partie de la Russie et s'ils font
ça, je préférais la détruire froidement
comme ça."
Euh et ça c'était en septembre, en
octobre novembre. Donc les Européens là,
il y a madame Nuland, il y a tout toutes
les fondations américaines aussi sur le
le terrain.
Fondation entre guillemets ou
Oui. Non
ou extension des services de
renseignement.
Tout le monde espionne de tout le monde.
C'est même pas ça. C'est
disons qu'il y avait une tentative de de
d'influence sur le cours de l'histoire
après ça. Euh
euh donc Yanokovic, qu'est-ce qu'il fait
?
J'ai à la veille de signer l'accord avec
les Européens, il change d'avis. Il dit
"Non, non, je je signe plus." Et là là,
les gens vont dans la rue et veulent
aller en Europe. Il Maidan numéro 2.
Mais j'y étais. Et là effectivement
arrive madame Nuland et quelques autres
qui distribuits pains.
Voilà. Et il y a l'occupation de la
place et puis ça dégénère. Au bout d'un
certain nombre de jours, on commence à
tirer avec des armes à feu. Alors qui
tire sur quoi ? On sait pas. Il y a
plusieurs thè mais des syndicats.
Voilà. Il y a il y a plusieurs thèses.
Ça tourne à la révolution. Les Russes
disent que c'est une révolution
fabriquée par la CIA. Les autres disent
que c'est plus compliqué que ça parce
que il y avait aussi une aspiration
aller vers l'Europe. C'est la vérité.
Donc c'est très complexe. C'est une
phase révolutionnaire. Les gens se font
tuer et Yanukovic finit par s'enfuir.
Et à partir du moment où il s'enfuit,
bah les la balle est dans le camp de
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ?
Minsk Minsk c'était en quelle année ?
Ben là ça commence avec euh
et pourquoi Angela Merkel et les
François Hollandes confesse que c'était
pour faire gagner du temps à l'Ukraine
pour se
alors ça c'est quand c'est devenu la
Normandie et quelques temps peut-être
quelques temps après. Donc dans cette
négociation il y a pas les Américains,
il y a les Français, les Allemands, les
Ukrainiens et les Russes. Et là aussi,
c'est une occasion ratée pour empêcher
la guerre.
Le dernier sommet du groupe D Normandie
s'est réuni à l'Élysée euh en décembre
2019.
juste après l'élection de de Zelinski
qui venait d'arriver, qui était un tout
petit acteur
arrivé complètement par hasard parce que
le système était totalement pourri et
les Ukrainiens ont dit "Bah, on va lui
donner sa chance à lui puisque tout le
monde est pourri. Faut faut voir ce que
c'était madame Timoschenko tout ça. Il
faisait des tonnes d'argent sur les
transferts de gaz Porchenko, le
fabricant de chocolat
avec des usin en Russie. Enfin, il y
avait une très très forte corruption.
Les Ukrainiens avaient perdu espoir.
Donc ils élisent le petit acteur juif
Zelinski qui qui est qui qui est tout
sauf un homme politique expérimenté et
qui arrive avec l'idée de de faire la
paix, d'en finir avec cette guerre
là-bas dans le Dbas et d'avoir des
relations normales avec les Russes. Et
euh
juste quand il dit ça, il fait une
conférence de presse pour dire ça,
là la Russe enflamme à Kief et tous les
tous les partis nationalistes disent pas
de trahison.
Vous entendez comme parti nationaliste
Svoboda bah toute la partie sector.
Oui, mais il y avait aussi tous les tous
les tous ceux qui avaient été battus
Porochenko et tout. Tout le monde dit à
Zelinski tu peux pas signer avec les
Russes. Donc il vient quand même à
l'Élysée.
On arrive à conclure une espèce de deal
assez avancé qu'on a appelé la formule
Steinmer parce que ça t c'était très
complexe la négociation. C'était quand
est-ce qu'on retire les forces russes ?
qui était officiellement pas là. On fait
des élections et le jour de l'élection
les forces se se retirent et on on crée
parce que tout ça tournait autour du
statut des territoires de l'est de
l'Ukraine
à l'intérieur de l'Ukraine, personne ne
remettait en cause les frontières de
l'Ukraine mais il fallait donner une
sorte d'autonomie à ces zones où il y
avait beaucoup de russophones.
Et pourquoi il fallait leur donner une
autonomie ? parce que parce que
ils étaient ils étaient ils étaient
sécessionnistes ou ils étaient sous le
feu euh ukrainien, ils étaient motivés
par les
au début au début il y avait pas de feu
ukrainien, il y avait une il y avait des
partis prorusses, il y a une population
d'origine russe qui était arrivée au 19e
siècle avec des gens qui parlaient le
russe et qui étaient assez lointain des
Ukrainiens de l'Ouest.
Et les Ukrainiens de l'Ouest, eux ont
commencé à dire "Bon, on va supprimer
l'apprentissage de la langue russe et on
va forcer tout le monde à être de vrais
Ukrainiens." Donc là, ça, il y a eu des
erreurs des deux côtés. Les Russes en
ont profité pour installer leurs propres
forces et créer une ce qu'ils appellent
ce qu'on appelle nous un conflit gelé.
Donc, il s'est créé une sorte de zone
d'occupation qui disait pas son nom. Ils
ont fait ça aussi en en Geéorgie. Il
contrôle deux territoires, l'OCTI du sud
et la Transnistrie aussi en Moldavie.
À peu près la même époque, je discutais
avec des copains reporter de guerre
ukrainien et reporter de guerre russe.
Ça, c'est un peu notre avantage.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut discuter nous
avec tout le monde. Et il me disait déjà
à l'époque que c'était une vraie
boucherie.
On en envoyé, on
il y avait 15000 morts hein quand même
dans cette dans cette affaire dans dans
le Donbas et les gens mouraient
beaucoup. Oui. Et et bon, la vérité
c'est qu'on n pas su du côté français et
allemand imposer
une solution. La radar ukrainienne n'a
jamais voté les lois d'autonomie.
Pourquoi elle a pas voté les lois
d'autonomie ? Parce que qui dit
autonomie disait que ces zonesl auraient
pu voter contre l'adhésion à l'OTAN.
Et donc il y allait de la souveraineté
de l'Ukraine. Les les Ukrainiens de de
Kiev ne voulaient pas de statut
différents pour ces minorités. euh
russophone à l'est. Donc il voulait un
pays unitaire et pas du tout euh toléré
de de c'est l'inverse de des d'un
système fédéral. En réalité, tout
tournait autour de ça. Comment modifier
la constitution ukrainienne ? Comment
donner l'autonomie à ces régionsl quatre
fameux les quatre provinces du Donbas ?
Et il y a jamais eu d'accord là-dessus.
Les les Russes eux faisaient semblant de
pas être impliqués en disant "Nous, on
n'y est pas, on y est pour rien." Euh
bien sûr qu' ils actionnaient les
séparatistes
et on avançait pas. La France et
l'Allemagne n'ont jamais pu.
Et est-ce que de l'autre côté les
États-Unis actionnaient les
nationalistes ukrainiens ?
Alors les États-Unis pendant toute cette
période c'est assez cocasse. Eux ils
ouvraient des bases de la CIA.
L'essentiel de l'entraînement de l'armée
ukrainienne pendant cette période,
c'était les Canadiens et les Anglais,
pas les Américains. Il y a eu très peu
d'armes. On
soit les Américain.
Ouais, si on veut. Ou ou
attraper un Canadien, c'est quand même
plus rigolo qu'attraper un américain
quand même. Non.
Ou oui. Non. Non. Le plus drôle dans
l'affaire, le plus drôle c'est Biden et
le fils Biden et l'interférence de
l'affaire ukrainienne dans les élections
américaines. Au moment de Trump.
Moment de Trump. Il y a vous avez suivi
ça. Il y a il y a eu toute il y a eu une
une entreprise de pénétration russe des
élection américaines et pour lutter
contre ça euh Rudy Juliani, l'ancien
maire de New York plus quelques quelques
personnages un peu douteux du style
Manaaphor ont voulu expliquer que non
l'interférence elle venait pas de
Russie, elle venait d'Ukraine et elle
venait d'Ukraine pourquoi ? Parce que le
fils Biden, c'est-à-dire le fils de
l'homme qui était chargé de l'Ukraine
dans l'administration Obama, le fils
Biden était corrompu et acheté par une
boîte de gaz russe ukraino-russe à Kief.
Et c'était vrai, le fils Biden était au
conseil d'administration d'une société
qui s'appelait Bourhisma.
Il gagnait plusieurs millions par an en
fait en en représentant son père quoi.
Le pointman de l'op de de de Obama pour
cette région c'était Biden père. Donc le
fils Biden est employé par la société
Burisma et les types de Trump disent
"Bah voilà, on va faire exploser ça la à
la figure de Biden." Et
Zelinski est élu. Non mais c'est une
histoire incroyable. C'est un roman
Zelinski était Zelinski élu,
il veut pouvoir être invité à la maison
blanche
parce que tout le monde s'en fout, ils
pas ils ont pas le temps, ça les
intéresse pas mais surtout c'est vous
dire à quel point aujourd'hui Zelinski
c'est le dieu, c'est Churchill à l'OP
personne veut le voir surtout pas la
maison blanche et puis il veut des armes
et les Américains veulent pas donner
d'armes parce que Blinken et Biden
disent non si on met des armes, les
Russes vont être encore plus d'armes, ça
va faire prolonger la guerre, c'est pas
la peine. C'était ça la ligne de
l'époque euh
sous Obama Biden. Et pendant ce tempslà,
le fils Biden fait de l'argent avec les
Ukrainiens. Trump
ensuite a envie de se payer Biden et le
de le décrédibiliser totalement. Quand
Zelitski est élu,
Trump, il y a cette fameuse conversation
téléphonique
avec euh avec Zelinski, entre Trump et
Zelinski
où Trump lui dit "Bon, j'ai besoin d'un
petit service.
Tu dégages la procureur,
tu lui il avait déjà dégagé
l'ambassadeur américain, c'était une
femme te fait respectable. Tu dégages le
le procureur et tu me lances une petite
poursuite sur le fils Biden qu'on sache
exactement ce qui s'est passé. Sauf que
dans la conversation, elle est écoutée
par les des collaborateurs du conseil de
sécurité dont un jeune de la CIA
qui est profondément choqué par le
chantage
et qui après avoir hésité décide de
saisir ses procureurs comme lanceur
d'alerte et il lance l'affaire.
Euh il y a eu beaucoup d'hésitation hein
euh pour le faire mais ils l'ont fait.
L'alerte a été retenue et ça a été
transmis au Congrès. Dès que c'est
transmis au Congrès, procédure de
destitution contre Trump. Et en fait, il
sera il y aura deux tentatives de
destitution
contre Trump. La première, c'est
l'Ukraine.
Et et ce qui est marrant, c'est que ce
qui est marrant, la Chambre des
représentants vote la destitution, il
sera sauvé au Sénat. Donc voilà, c'est
comme j'écris dans le bouquin, voilà
l'intérêt édition Audil Jacob. Euh euh
donc c'est tout sauf une grande
stratégie. Vous m'entendez ce que je
veux dire ? Les Russes disent "Moi, je
vais garder l'Ukraine." J'ouvre une
parenthèse. Vous parlez de l'autre côté
en B, vous parlez d'Hunter Biden.
Vous parlez d'unter Hunter Biden, le
fils Biden. Hunter,
vous avez suivi un petit peu son
histoire quand il a déposé son
ordinateur portable pour faire réparer.
Il y avait quoi là-dedans ? Il y avait
ça, il y avait il y avait il y avait il
y avait d'autres trucs. Il y avait un
peu de cou de craqu il y avait des
mineurs. Il y avait il y avait des
choses comme ça. Moi, j'ai pas lu ce qu'
avait dans son ordinateur. Ce que je
sais c'est qu'il y avait il était aussi
question de cette correspondance avec la
société Bourhisma et cetera. Donc mais
en fait ils le font tomber sur des
histoires de possession d'armes pas sur
Vous inquiétez pas la la drogue et les
mineurs, ça va venir dans pas longtemps.
Quel regard vous façon Biden est sorti
maintenant. Biden est sorti,
il a été sorti et et c'est Camala Haris
la candidate.
Il a été sorti par le clan Obama.
Il a été sorti non, il a été sorti par
l'étatmajor du parti démocrate qui était
tétanisé à l'idée de perdre de perdre
des députés, des sénateurs. C'est
surtout ça. Biden allait perdre mais
derrière ça risqué d'entraîner la
déroute dans les chambres et dans les
chambres c'est l'argent.
C'est pas ce qui va se passer là aux
prochaines élections américaines le 5
novembre.
C'est très compliqué.
5 novembre, ils sont tellement proches
que personne aujourd'hui, je dis bien
personne,
regardez quel sondage ?
Je regarde tous ceux que je lis tous les
jours dans le New York Times et le
Washington Post, c'est extrêmement
proche. C'est très difficile de savoir
qui va l'emporter.
C'est extrêmement proche dans le New
York Times et l'OP.
Non, c'est proche dans tous les sondages
qui sont cités dans il y a il y a pas
vraiment de de de candidats qui creus.
Si Trump met 10 points à Camela Haris,
ce sera une défaite des instituts de
sondage des médias.
Moi j'y crois pas. Je crois pas qu'il
mette 10 points. Non. 5
bien tassé.
Non, ce qui est ce qui ce qui est ça
aussi ça relève du roman ce qui s'est
passé avec Biden. C'estàd que pendant
des mois et des mois, il y a eu un
coverup
de l'entourage direct de Biden pour
cacher le fait que le type était devenu
malheureusement pour lui grab. que je
dis sans méchanceté, vu mon âge
maintenant, je méfie de
Oui, mais enfin genoux peut-être, mais
euh la vieillesse peut vous donner des
coups terribles. Et cet homme-là qui a
été un fringant, il a fait que ça dans
toute sa vie, Biden, que de la politique
euh là, il était quand même très atteint
et le le somum a été atteint aussi,
c'est quand il y a eu des célébrations
d'anniversaire du débarquement et il
arrivait, il savait pas où il était.
C'est sa femme qui
là où il y avait pas la Russie. C'est
ça.
Voilà. là où il y avait pas la Russie
mais il y avait une une Amérique
complètement inexistante et puis il y a
eu le débat au mois de juin le débat
contre contre Trump où là il s'est
littéralement liquéfié et c'est là que
les l'étatmajor démocrate a dit bon
coupe on arrête les frais et on on
trouve un autre candidat et il restait
très peu de temps.
Revenons sur l'Ukraine et la
l'apocalypse que ça risque de nous
emmener. Là on est reparti sur des
manœuvres type guerre froide à la papa.
C'est-à-dire, je t'ouvre un conflit à
gauche, tu m'ouvres un conflit à droite,
je t'ouvre un conflit au milieu, tu
m'envoies un conflit a-dessus de ma
tête, je finance un groupe de
terroristes à gauche à droite et j'en
passé des meilleurs. Vous avec vos 73
ans et et quelques poussières, vous le
voyez comment le 21e siècle ? Est-ce que
on va avoir une guerre ouverte
Chine-Amérique ? Est-ce qu'on va avoir
le dindon de la farce français, européen
et allemand dépessé sur l'hôtel de la
mondialisation pour que les États-Unis
et la Chine gagnent un peu de temps
entre-temps ? Comment ça se passe ?
Bon, c'est une histoire très complexe
que j'essaie de traiter dans le livre.
Je vous dis, il y a deux problèmes. Le
problème numéro 1, c'est comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un semblant d'ordre
au centre de l'Europe
sans droit international, sans
institution internationale respective.
Non non. Comment on fait le l'accord de
paix en fait ?
Non non, il va y avoir un accord de paix
au bout d'un moment sur l'Ukra
qui va qui va pouvoir échanger avec les
Russes et se mettre entre les Russes et
les Ukrainiens. Macron est considéré
comme un puceau touriste de la politique
étrangère. Les Russes disent "Ils nous
font une macronnerie". C'est-à-dire il
respecte jamais sa parole, il nous met
des couteaux dans le dos et puis les
quelques crétins diplomates qui nous ont
envoyé tiennent pas la route qui on va
mettre au milieu.
Non. Oui, à un moment c'est une guerre
d'usure et tout le monde est fatigué.
Ah bah les Russes, ils ont pas l'air
très fatigués là.
Un terme, ils ont besoin d'arrêter
aussi.
euh beaucoup de morts euh une économie
de guerre, ça se paye sur la la la un
moment ou un autre euh avec l'élection
américaine à la sortie, il va y avoir
une négociation et cette négociation
intensification du
et cette négociation vont il peut encore
une fois ils sont lourdement usés des
deux côtés. Si l'armée russe était quel
c'est quoi vos alors côté ukrainien je
veux bien mais côté russe c'est quoi vos
sources ? ce que je lis, ce que je vois.
Quand on voit le cornu est obligé de
dîner avec Marine Le Pen pour avoir des
informations sur ce qui se passe en
Russie, est-ce qu'on passe pas encore
pour des pigeons ?
Non mais attendez, vous multipliez les
sujets là, vous m'avez posé une
question, qu'est-ce qui se passe
maintenant ?
Qui on va mettre entre les Ukrainien et
les Russ ?
Mais non, mais les Ukrainiens et les bah
malheureusement pas nous parce qu'on
s'est discrédité, mais il peut y avoir
des Turcs par exemple. Les Turcs ont été
les premiers médiateurs. On a oublié ça
aussi, c'est dans mon livre avec les
avec même les documents en annexe. Euh 2
semaines après le début de la guerre,
Russes et Ukrainiens s'assoient autour
de la table pour arrêter les frais quand
même. D'abord sous médiation biélorusse
puis ensuite sous médiation turc et ils
arrivent à construire ce qui ressemble à
un accord de paix au mois d'avril 2022.
Et pourquoi ça a foiré ? Ça a foiré pour
plusieurs raisons. D'abord parce que les
Ukrainiens commençaient à croire qu'ils
allaient gagner. Ils avaient battu les
Russes à Kief et les Russes étaient en
train de se retirer vers Karkiv et euh
donc il pensait qu'il pouvait gagner.
Euh les Américains et surtout Boris
Johnson sont allés à une Ukraine en
disant faut jamais traiter avec Poutine,
c'est un voleur, c'est un tueur, il faut
pas signer avec eux, on va vous donner
de l'argent. Et c'est ce qui s'est
passé. On a commencé à mettre de
l'argent au mois d'avril. Et la
troisième chose, c'est qu'il y a eu
Boucha et Irpine, c'est-à-dire les
images
l'image de massacre. Donc ça ça a
beaucoup choqué l'opinion publique et
les négociations on été interrompu par
la partie ukrainienne. Mais le fond du
sujet, il est déjà dans l'accord à
savoir où est-ce qu'on trace la ligne la
ligne de front que nous nous les
occidentaux, on reconnaîtra pas.
Exactement comme pour l'Allemagne de
l'Est. On n' jamais reconnu l'existence
de la de l'Est ni de la fracture entre
les deux Allemagnes. On a eu on a parlé
à l'Allemagne de l'Est mais mais on n'
jamais admis la la partition définitive
de l'Allemagne. Idem pour la Corée ou
pour Chypre, on peut être dans une
situation où il y a une ligne de front
et puis un jour ou l'autre les deux
peuples se rapprochent. On règle ça dans
un dans le cas d'un traité de paix
définitif. Donc ça c'est la première
chose. Et l'autre chose ce sont les
fameuses garanties de sécurité.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'Ukraine une
fois qu'elle une fois qu'on a ce cette
cet accord sur la frontière, enfin sur
même temporaire ? Quel est le statut de
l'Ukraine ? Bah, on retourne à la case
départ, ce sera la neutralité, pas dans
l'OTAN. Et si c'est pas dans l'OTAN, qui
apporte des garanties de sécurité à
l'Ukraine à ce moment-là ? Et ça c'est
un défi majeur parce que les Américains
ils vont pas rester en Europe, ils vont
aller vers la Chine. Donc il va falloir
que la France, l'Allemagne,
l'Angleterre, la Pologne prennent en
charge la sécurité de l'Ukraine. un pays
un pays attendez pays euh détruit sur le
plan économique
et démographique
démographique qui a perdu 20 millions
d'habitants depuis l'indépendance euh
mais surarmé politiquement très instable
et surarmé militairement puisque au
sortir de la guerre euh il y a plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'hommes en
Ukraine en armes aguéri. Donc on va être
dans une situation qui va être assez
complexe. Ça c'est le problème des
Européens.
les années qui viennent. Ça c'est c'est
ce qui nous pas et j'entends personne
travailler là-dessus. C'est ça qui me
c'est ça qui me finit me désespérer.
C'est qu'il y a pas un type il y a pas
un responsable politique français qui
dit bon maintenant il faudrait peut-être
qu'on s'occupe de à quoi ça va
ressembler après la guerre. Qui
je vous pose une question. Vous avez été
dans le gouvernement vous connaissez des
diplomates, vous avez bourlingué de
l'Afghanistan passant par l'Irak. Vous
avez vous êtes vraiment quelqu'un qui
est d'ailleurs méconnu pour notre
génération alors que vous êtes une
petite perle de géopolitique.
Vous êtes trop bon cher ami. Trop bon.
Non
non non attendez les coups de bâton
viennent.
Quand on dit il y a personne qui
travaille sur le après
personne
mais c'est forcément révélateur de
quelque chose.
Bah c'est la vérité révélateur d'un pays
qui sort de l'histoire. Vous
comprenezance ?
C'est un pays qui a décidé de sortir de
l'histoire qui marche au chéquier et au
guichets.
Vous parlez de la France ou de
Oui, je parle de notre pays qui me
désespère.
L'idée que la France pèse encore,
qu'elle puisse non pas seulement faire
des discours et des de la diplomatie
hôtelière, mais peser sur le cours des
choses. Tout le monde s'en fout. Tout le
monde s'en fout. Et moi, je regarde,
vous pensez que la question est soulevée
à l'Assemblée nationale, de quoi il
parle ? Il parle de budget, il parle de
coup t ordu entre
on est de retour au pire de la 3e et de
la 4e République. Il y a plus d'envie si
vous voulez. Il y a plus d'envie. Il y a
envie de vacances, il y a envie de
guichet, il y a envie et puis il y a une
situation économique qui est on faut
bien voir que depuis 40 ans, on a ruiné
ce pays, on l'a désindustrialisé. On
continue de Lipran, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? On file le truc aux Américains. Mais
pourquoi ? Et qui le fait ? Ça la
question. Alst la farge et tant d'autres
et tant d'autres et qui le fait ben
est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
alors je parle pour notre pays on
reviendra sur l'Ukraine, les États-Unis,
la Chine et et l'Iran peut-être
j'aimerais bien. Est-ce que vous avez
pas l'impression que Oui, on a le temps
pu
19h47.
Est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
que la France
est en train de se faire désosser comme
l'ex Union soviétique lors de son
effondrement ? On vend les bijoux de
famille,
il y a de la corruption à gogo. Il y en
a qui s'en mettent plein les poches,
tout le monde regarde ailleurs et tout
Paris est acheté.
Oui.
Par le Qatar not. Oui.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous les
Français ? On arrive, on commence à
sortir, on est en train de de laisser
une situation où on va être les grands
cocus de l'histoire. C'estàd que qui va
gagner à la sortie de l'Ukraine ? Pas
les Russes parce que les Russes Poutine,
il a fait il a fait à mon avis une
erreur stratégique parce qu'à la fin
qu'est-ce qui qui se passe ? L'OTAN
s'élargit, la Baltique devient un
lacotien,
les amerlogues se sont réveillés, ça va
être compliqué et lui il va devenir
vasal des Chinois parce que à terme, il
s'affaiblit, donc c'est pas terrible.
Mais mais bon, c'est ça qu'il a voulu,
c'est ça qu'il a fait parce que encore
une fois, il ne pouvait pas renoncer à
l'Ukraine comme beaucoup de Russes
d'ailleurs. Bon
donc lui, il est pas vraiment gagnant
même si apparemment il aura gagné la
guerre. On dira qu'il a pas gagné.
Enfin, peu importe
la France cocule.
Mais mais mais ce qui se passe, c'est
que au final, c'est la Chine qui gagne.
L'Europe devient le champ de bataille
commercial entre les États-Unis et la
Chine. Parce que si Trump est élu, vous
allez voir les les barrières douanières.
Tout ce qui rentre pas aux États-Unis,
on va le retrouver sur le marché
européen en venant de Chine. Donc nous,
on va devenir le terrain de jeu des
grosses boîtes américaines et chinoises.
Et personne va nous faire de cadeaux.
Ça, je peux vous le dire parce que j'ai
j'ai négocié aussi avec et les et les
uns et les autres. Personne nous fera de
cadeaux. Alors, comme on a un appareil
industriel qui est en train de fondre
comme la neige au soleil parce que
personne s'en occupe et parce que les
décisions sont prises par une côterie de
haut fonctionnaires qui eux-mêmes vont
faire du fric après dans le privé. Parce
que c'est ça le la maladie. Quand De
Gaul crée l'ENAT, il crée un corps de
haut fonctionnaire pour redresser la
France, pas pour faire du business.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au fil
des années ? La très haute fonction
publique française, elle a fagocité la
politique. Ils sont tous passés par
l'énat, les Hollandes, les Chirak et
cetera, les maire, tout ce qu'on veut.
Et puis et puis ils sont fagocités
l'industrie. Ils sont rentrés dans les
dans les banques et dans l'industrie
sans sans rien y connaître. Puis en
général, ils viennent tous de l'inspect
c'est que un, on n pas fait les réformes
nécessaires pour rendre la France
compétitive. de on a perdu le sens
stratégique, on a laissé désosser des
bouts entiers la Syrie, l'énergie et
allons-y. Forfiture,
bien sûr.
D'accord. Mais si c'est une fortfeture.
On a bien des services de renseignement
qui font de la guerre économique, du
renseignement interne externe, ils sont
pas aveugles. Ils sont quoi sont ils
sont muets, ils ont les oreilles qui
saignent, il faut leur mettre des coups
de bâton. Bah eux, leur rôle c'est il y
a très peu de gens qui sortent ou alors
comme dans le cas vous souvenez j'avais
lancé l'affaire Alstom et et
l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines mais je l' fait moi tout
seul. J'ai demandé une réunion avec le
président de l'assemblée. Ils ont ils
sont tâtés. Oui, on va faire une étude
là-dessus. Et c'est là qu'on est tombé
sur Pierucci et la Feralstom. Et
Pierucci lui comme il était il est allé
en tôle deux fois aux États-Unis, il
avait peut-être quelque chose.
Oui. En plus oui, ils Island c'est c'est
pas un cadeau. Et donc il a dit les
choses mais il était lui-même la victime
de tout ça. Euh
d'accord. La France est en train de se
faire ouvrir en deux. Il va rien nous
rester que nos yeux pour pleurer.
Bah c'està-dire que quand on
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Ben, c'est-à-dire qu'on on a à faire à
un peuple inquiet, malheureux,
euh excédé. Là, ils vont prendre 40
milliards de taxes en plus. Ça va être
terrible pour la pour la croissance.
Plus personne va avoir d'argent en fait.
Ça va taper sur tout le monde. Donc,
ralentissement en plus d'une économie
qui était déjà pas loin de zéro pour
progrès. Donc, et pourquoi ? Pourquoi ça
? Parce qu'on est incapable de faire des
économies. parce qu'il y a pas la
volonté politique d'aller et et et que
comme toujours en France, on monte on
monte au rideau dans les extrêmes, on
échange des des insultes, des trucs mais
on règle pas les problèmes et c'est tout
à fait désespérant.
Et ben vous savez comment ça va se
terminer cette histoire ? Quand tout le
monde sera à genou, quand on aura tous
marre de courber les Chines face à une
déliquacence de notre classe politique,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Ça va taper
ça risque
les gilets jaunes c'était
c'était
ça risque
Disneyland par rapport à ce qu'il
mais vous savez le le le drame il est
profond. Alors il y a quelque chose
qu'on partage avec d'autres Européens
parce que la la descente de l'Europe
elle est générale. Ça je le dis aussi
dans mon livre entre 2008 et aujourd'hui
la taille du PIB européen qui était du
même niveau que les Américains en 2008 a
été coupée en deux de moitié. Donc on
est deux fois moins riche alors qu'on
était au même niveau que les Américains
en 2008. Donc ça va très vite. Il y a
pas de gafam européenne. Il y a elles
viennent se gaver en Europe sans payer
d'impôts. Est-ce que vous trouvez normal
de de prendre des taxis Uber qui
prennent 25 % de la de commission sur le
la course du chauffeur ou des Airbnb qui
payent pas d'impôts en France ou
quasiment pas ou
des commissions de p
parce que parce que ils vont les payer
en Irlande parce qu'on considère que
l'Irlande a le droit d'avoir des impôts
à 15 % parce que c'est l'Union
européenne. Mais c'est de la blague
enfin. Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc ?
D'accord. On a bien fait le constat que
c'était de la blague.
Non mais je veux dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on se fait enfiler des choses
pareilles ? Moi quand j'étais je vous
raconter l'accepte.
Je vais vous raconter
quand vous avez marre de vous faire
enfiler, qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Vous appelez vous appelez un médecin.
Euh je raconter une anecdote qui m'a qui
m'a beaucoup marqué.
J'ai j'étais à ce moment-là
à l'Europe
et euh je lis dans la presse qu'on va
acheter des trains bombardiers mais que
nous on peut pas vendre des trains
français au Canada.
Alors j'appelle mes gars du cabinet, je
dis attendez moi j'ai des souvenirs de
fac de droit. J'avais étudié le commerce
international, il y avait un article 24
paragraphe 4, je m'en souvenais du GAT
dans lequel il y a une réciprocité. Le
principe de réciprocité c'est un
principe fondamental de droit
international. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas vendre de train au Canada ? Ah
ben je sais pas monsieur le ministre.
Euh bah j'ai dit vous savez ce qu'on va
faire ? On va soulever la question
demain au conseil. Il y avait un Conseil
européen le lendemain et je dis demain
la France demandera la réciprocité à
base la base de tout dans les marchés
publics. Vous rentrez chez moi, je
rentre chez vous sinon il y a pas vous
rentrez pas. Réciprocité. Alors, ils me
disent "Mais mais alors ça il se
renseignent, ils reviennent une heure
après en me disant "Mais attendez, Pery
veut pas
à Matignon, le SGCI veut pas et à
l'Élysée, ils veulent pas non plus." Ah
et pourquoi ils veulent pas ? Bah parce
que Bruxelles est contre et les
Allemands sont contre.
C'est une blague. C'est une blague.
Texto. Mais si c'est comme ça, vous
savez ce qu'on Alors, on a passé la
journée comme ça et puis j'ai dit "Vous
allez quand même me faire un mail, vous
faites tourner à toutes ces institutions
en leur disant "Demain, je fais ça,
est-ce que quelqu'un peut être contre ?"
Il y a jamais eu de ma naturelle.
Personne, aucun des haut fonctionnaires
dans les endroits en question n'a dit
"Monsieur le minier, vous avez pas le
droit de demander la réciprocité." OK.
Le lendemain matin, le lendemain matin à
7h. Bah bien sûr, il pouvait pas il
pouvait pas dire la France refuse la
réciprocité. C'était absurde. Il y a un
ministre français qui dit je vais
demander ça. Personne dans les endroits
où on bloquait mais en douce personne
dit on est ouvertement contre la
réciprocité. lendemain matin euh où je
prends le talis de 7h je sais pas quoi,
enfin l'hor tôt le matin, je m'installe
et hop, ils arrivent sur moi comme une
comme les moineaux les fonctionnaires
des différentes SGCI parce que comité
interministériel sur l'Europe de ma
ce ministre vous pouvez pas vous pouvez
pas faire ça. Comment je peux pas faire
? Ah bah non mais vous me l'avez écrit,
j'ai un ordre du président comme quoi je
peux pas demander la réciprocité. Ah non
et ben je vais le faire.
Je l'ai fait et vous savez quand est-ce
qu'on a inscrit la réciprocité dans les
textes européens ? 12 ans après. 12 ans
après.
Alors qu'on se fait enfiler par les
Chinois, les Vietnamiens, les tout ce
qu'on américain les cat
le fond du sujet c'est que ça fonctionne
plus. L'histoire européenne ne
fonctionne plus. Vous pouvez pas vous
pouvez pas à 27 prendre des décisions
stratégiques sur la défense France
Est-ce que la France doit sortir de
l'Europe ? Je vais je vais vous dire si
mon scénario sur la prègerre en Ukraine
se vérifie, à savoir qu'on va être
malheureusement incapable, faute de le
vouloir, de gérer la suite, alors il y a
un risque pour l'Union européenne.
C'estàd que il est pas sûr qu'elle
survit en l'État. Ce qui est marrant, si
j'ose dire, c'est que pendant ce
temps-là, Ursule, moi je l'appelle
Ursule Layen Ursul. Ah non, je supporte
pas.
On est sur Syerview, il faut prendre un
peu de niveau.
Ah oui, j'ai pas Urula Vlen.
Madame Ursula Vaneren,
chef autoproclamé de l'Europe, n'as
quelques petites histoires au
département de la défense en Allemagne.
Oui, entre autres. Oui. Qui a été
exfiltré par Merkel qui n'en pouvait
plus de cette dame en Allemagne. Souvent
le cas d'ailleurs des gens qu'on voit à
Bruxelles n'en peut plus à l'interne.
Donc madame Ursula a décidé que la
solution c'était d'élargir. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut ? Elle veut faire
rentrer l'Ukraine, la Moldavie et tous
les Balkans. Donc on va devenir une un
mini ONU, 40 pays, 40 et quelques pays.
Comment vous prenez une décision
là-dessus ? Et pourquoi elle fait-elle ?
Elle le fait parce qu'elle pense que
l'Allemagne va rester une puissance
dominante, que tous les petits vont vont
graviter autour de l'Allemagne et qu'on
va revenir à la mythel Europa qui était
le rêve avant la Première Guerre
mondiale. Mais si c'est ça l'histoire,
il va y avoir un problème en France
parce que nous nous les Français nous
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on sorte de l'Union
européenne ?
Il faut prendre des mesures.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas attendre ?
Attendez, je vais répondre à votre
question. Le le l'objectif c'est
l'intérêt national. Donc il faut que
nous soyons à même de prendre des
mesures qui vont nous permettre de
reconstruire notre économie et notre
industrie. Pour ça, ça veut dire que
comment il a fait de Gaulle euh en 58 ?
Le bon sens.
Bah, il a fait que il a fait que il
pouvait dévaluer, il pouvait prendre des
droits de douane et il pouvait investir
dans les endroits stratégiques. En
France, il faut faire la même chose.
Alors, le problème, c'est qu'on ne peut
plus dévaluer, qu'on ne peut plus
prendre les décisions au commerce
extérieur. Vous savez que le commerce
extérieur en Europe, il est fédéralisé.
C'estàd qu'il y a si vous êtes ministre
du commerce extérieur, ce que j'ai été,
vous allez découvrir qu'il y a un gars
au-dessus de vous qui est le ministre,
le commissaire européen en commerce
extérieur. C'est lui qui une fois les
mandats signés arbitre au nom de
l'Europe. Donc si les Allemands sont
plus puissants et veulent absolument
vendre des bagnoles en Amérique latine,
bah nous on se mange le mercur qui va
faire du mal à nos agriculteurs. C'est
ça l'histoire, c'est que le le commerce
extérieur français n'est pas piloté par
des gens élus en France. Il est piloté
par quelqu'un
de la Commission qui va prendre au nom
entre guillemets de l'intérêt européen
qui va prendre des décisions en
balançant des voitures allemandes contre
des je sais pas quoi des du maïs
français ou jeou du lait ou de la viande
et et et ça c'est c'est très compliqué
de de refabriquer un tissu industriel
solide en France si on n pas le contrôle
de ça. De la même façon, c'est pas
normal de voir les gars femmes faire un
énorme business en France et payer des
impôts en Irlande. Ça, je peux pas
l'admettre. J'ai beaucoup de mal. Et et
que l'Irlande est devenu un pays où les
gens crevaient de faim l'Irlande.
Rappelez-vous, ils ont été peu 900 ans
d'occupation anglaise, pas cadeau. Et
deuxièmement, dès le 19e siècle, les
migration massive vers les États-Unis,
il mourait de faim. Aujourd'hui, c'est
un des pays les plus prospères d'Europe.
Pourquoi ? Ils ont un budget en
excédent. Pourquoi ? parce que les
impôts payés par les par les
multinationales vont en Irlande et pas
dans les pays où où ils vendent leurs
produits et ça tout le monde accepte ça.
Bon bah
le corps diplomatique français supprimé
pratiquement par Emmanuel Macron,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? C'est une
tragédie parce qu'il y a énormément de
de gens de très grande qualité et qui
connaissent bien les sujets. On avait un
on avait un réseau diplomatique qui
était envier, qui était le trè du monde.
Mais à force de couper le peu d'argent
qu'il y a dedans pour pour donner ça
dans des guichets diverses et variés,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire quoi dans des
guets diverses et variés ? Bah
c'estàd qu'on a une une pompe,
on file toutes sortes de de d'argent à
des gens qui ont jamais contribué. Quand
vous avez 500000 personnes qui rentrent
en France par an, je vais être clair
hein, quand vous avez des vagues
migratoires de cette taille et qu'on
entretient des gens avec de l'argent
public, il est sûr que vous allez ruiner
le reste du de l'économie. Ça coûte
vraiment beaucoup d'argent.
Combien ça coûte ?
Ah ça il y a toutes sortes toutes sortes
de de d'estimations. La France n'a
jamais voulu voir combien il rentraaiit
de gens. On le fait que depuis
récemment. La France n'a jamais voulu
savoir combien ça coûtait. On continua
des avec des phrases creuses.
L'immigration est une chance pour la
France. Euh voilà. Non, la vérité c'est
que c'est très compliqué quand on va euh
comme c'est le cas de nous tous euh on
va dans un vous allez faire faire une
radio ou quelque chose pour parce que
vous êtes malade, vous allez payer. Vous
payez vous payez la visite et puis vous
payez une code part. Sauf si vous avez
une maladie extrêmement lourde, vous
allez payer une code part et vous devez
prendre une mutuelle pour compenser les
les le reste à charge. Mais si vous
arrivez de je sais pas où, du Sud Soudan
par exemple,
mauvais exemple, c'est là il y a une
vraie guerre mais vous arriviez du Mali
par exemple ou du Sénégal, vous avez
vous avez accès à la couverture totale
que ce soit la ME, la CMU et si vous
êtes en attente de régularisation va
même vous donner un quart de crédit avec
une dotation quotidienne mais avec des
gens qui n'ont jamais contribué
à à à notre à notre gâteau national, à
notre production. production nationale.
Donc ça aussi ça va un jour ou l'autre
donner des des signes de fracturation
parce qu'en plus on a fait à une
population qui à des populations qui
contrairement à ce qui a été raconté
sont pas les mêmes que les autochtones.
Moi j'entends dire puisqu'on vous êtes
sur ce sujet d'immigration
c'est vous qui l'avez mis sur la table.
Euh non mais c'est un sujet majeur pour
l'avenir de notre pays. On entend les
bons esprits, les soi-disants
démographes vous expliquer que la France
a toujours été un pays d'immigration.
C'est pas vrai. On ter d'accueil,
on a jamais été un pays d'immigration
avant les années 20 parce qu'on avait
perdu 5 millions de jeunes français
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale. Et
là, on a commencé à ouvrir. Mais à qui
on a ouvert ? On a ouvert aux Espagnols,
aux Italiens, aux Polonais, c'està-dire
aux gens qui étaient trahis
portugais
portugais aux traditions de
judéocchrétienne. Ensuite, qu'est-ce qu'
a fait De Gaul ? De Gaul, il a voulu
qu'on sorte d'Algérie uniquement pour
éviter que on se retrouve face à une
immigration massive. Or, cette
immigration massive, elle est venue 10
ans après l'indépendance et le Conseil
d'État a considéré que le il fallait que
ces gens fassent venir leur famille. Et
donc, on est passé d'une immigration de
travail voulue par le CNPF de l'époque
qui voulait du travailleur pas cher. On
est passé d'une immigration de travail,
une immigration de peuplement.
Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve avec une
très forte population immigrée euh qui
réclame, on peut le comprendre
d'ailleurs son identité qui qui dit en
plus que l'identité française voilà, il
y a des choses à prendre et pas à
apprendre. On est en train de vivre des
trucs très très importants parce qu'il y
a une remise en cause si vous voulez de
euh
tout à l'ensemble de ce que nous
appelons les valeurs de la République.
En réalité, on veut parler de la France.
C'est quoi l'histoire de la France ? La
plupart des gens qui arrivent
considèrent que l'histoire de France
commence avec le jour de leur arrivée.
Ils ont aucune espèce de début de
connaissance de ce qui s'est passé
avant. ni a envie de savoir d'ailleurs.
Ni envie de savoir. Il y a très peu de
gens qui font cette démarche mais mais
très peu. Bon alors on est en train de
se balcaniser, de se libiser.
On a des facteurs on est en train
on a des facteurs économiques des terres
des facteurs géopolitiques, délétaire
des facteurs climatiques délétaires des
facteurs migratoires délétaire.
Oui.
Et on a Stéphane Séjourné ministre des
affaires étrangères. On a fait
on avait
Au revoir.
Grand moment. Ouais.
Ouais.
Ouais. de solitude.
Ouais. Qu'est-ce que je veux dire ?
Malheureusement, le tableau est est très
difficile et
je parle souvent avec des gens de ma
génération
qui ont qui ont connu la France d'il y a
50 ans, qui ont qui ont connu la période
où moi quand je suis rentré de j'ai fait
des études à Harvard, j'ai jamais été à
LENA mais quand j'ai fini ma scolarité
en France, j'ai voulu aller aux
États-Unis, j'ai fait je suis rentré
d'Arvard
quand je quand je suis revenu
Je voulais revenir. J'avais des offres
pour rester aux États-Unis.
Mais mais moi j'étais fier d'être
français européen. L'avenir, il était en
Europe et en France au début des années
70 mais on pétait le feu. On allait
devenir l'endroit avec la culture en
plus bien mieux que le pays du
hamburger.
Avec le style,
on était content de revenir quoi. Moi,
j'étais fier. Je aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je regarde les jeunes et je
regarde les types de ma génération
disent "Punaise, heureusement qu'on a
pas 20 ans" parce que ça va être très
très compliqué pour les jeunes
générations de gérer l'équation en
question.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a plus
d'intellectuel, parce qu'il y a plus de
base, parce qu'il y a plus de
fondamentaux. Parce que c'est très
difficile déjà. C'est très très
difficile. Il y a plus de on peut pas se
raccrocher à beaucoup de choses. En 45,
la France avait été détruite, occupé
mais il y avait il y avait une Amérique
surpuissante. Il y avait un tir monde
qui n'était que le Tiermonde
sous-développé. La Chine était derrière
ses murs. C'était assez simple, il y
avait la guerre froide avec les Russes
mais globalement l'Amérique était
puissante et elle a elle a puissamment
l'aidé l'Europe à s'intégrer. Elle a
reconstruit l'Allemagne, le Japon et
c'était assez simple. De Gaul, lui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ? Bah, il a
profissé de ça tout en imposant une
ligne indépendante entre les États-Unis
et la Russie.
Quand vous avez vu Sarintégrer dans le
conseil de l'OTAN, quand vous avez vu
Sarco que vous connaissez.
Oui, bien sûr.
Sarco qui nous réintègre dans le conseil
de l'OTAN.
Non, il n'a pas réintégré. il a il a euh
remis la France dans le commandement
intégré mais pas dans le le commandement
des forces nucléaires. Le commandement
intégré c'est une réunion entre les
généraux qui qui n'implique enfin
tellement aujourd'hui il y a tellement à
faire sur le plan militaire que c'est
vraiment la dernière question. La la la
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui,
c'est pas tellement de réintégrer le
commandement militaire, c'est savoir si
les Américains vont rester dans le temps
et si Trump va arriver.
Si on paye 2,5 % de notre pay.
Ouais, je suis pas sûr.
Fondamentalement,
on a le temps. La majeure partie sont
très panés, s'intéressent pas aux
questions internationales. On est dans
le guidon entre leur problème
d'inflation, d'inflation sur la bouffe,
sur les appartements. Impossible de se
loger, impossible de se chauffer. On va
avoir 60 milliards d'impôts en plus sur
la tête.
Ça va mal se terminer cette histoire. La
classe politique, vous pensez qu'elle va
faire quoi ? Elle va s'exfiltrer en
Suisse pour éviter de se faire Pourquoi
vous rigolez ?
Non, il faut pas non plus dépeindre
l'apocalypse, mais c'est vrai que nous
sommes au devant de de de choses très
très très difficiles euh
très difficile. Et malheureusement euh
grâce à monsieur Macron, on a une
situation, on peut pas faire d'élections
d'ici l'été prochain. Donc, il peut pas
y avoir de cap sérieux pris parce que
quels que soient les Je connais bien
Barnier, je connais un certain nombre de
mes camarades sont au gouvernement,
ils vont avec cœur mais c'est
impossible. Comment voulez-vous prendre
des des décisions majeures sanctionnées
par des lois quand vous n'avez pas le
début d'une majorité pour avoir une loi
? Supposez que vous vouliez par exemple
euh créer un délit, remettre le délit de
présence des des illégales des des
immigrés en France, bah vous aurez
jamais une majorité pour la faire
passer. Si vous voulez faire des peines
planchées, vousz pas de loi non plus.
Donc Retaillot peut dire ce qu'il croit
à être juste et je le soutiens
simplement il a pas les moyens de sa
politique. Euh pour faire des économies,
il faut que vous ayez une majorité qui
vous dise "Bah tiens, on va supprimer le
Conseil économiste et social. Il y a il
y a 500 millions d'euros à à ramasser.
On va supprimer telle et telle agence
qui sert à rien. On va récupérer des
milliards d'économies. Mais pour ça, il
faut une loi. Il faut avoir d'abord le
courage de se confronter à à ses
résistances et ensuite faire voter une
loi si vous n'avez il y a pas de
majorité du tout. Donc comment on est
dans un système totalement éclaté sans
précédent.
Est-ce que vous êtes inquiet pour la
stabilité de l'euro ?
Je suis inquiet pour pour notre déficit
à nous parce que le jour où les marchés
décident de se payer la France, ça va
être grave. C'est-à-dire s'il y a des
fonds vautour qui veulent attaquer la
dette française,
bah un moment euh à un moment ils vont
attaquer la dette française. On a déjà
dépassé l'Espagne et la Grèce, ils
regardent les chiffres. S'il y en est
un taux d'intérêt,
bah oui, ils vont va monter les taux
d'intérêt, ça va être de plus en plus
cher. C'est aujourd'hui le le
remboursement de la dette est supérieur
au budget de la défense alors qu'on a
besoin d'une défense. Donc on vit à
crédit. On vit à crédit tous les jours.
Et quand quand je vois cette quand je
vois la GabJ qui continue tous les
jours, ils ont toujours rien compris.
Pourquoi ils ont pas compris ? Ils ont
pas compris. Ils ont peur que le sevrage
de la Gabg soit tellement délétaire pour
la classe politique qui a une seule
capacité, c'est-à-dire essayer
d'intriguer pour s'assurer un petit
futur. Est-ce que vous avez pas peur ?
Du moins, est-ce que eux ils n'ont pas
peur de se faire rafraîchir la nuque ?
Bah à un moment, je pense que la la
violence malheureusement euh la France
estant la France quand le système est
bloqué ça ça va dans la rue et ça risque
de se terminer comme Louis-Philippe
parce que Macron, il ressemble de plus
en plus à Louis-Philippe.
Ouais
pour pour les jeunes qui nous suivent
pas, Louis Philippe il il cour dans la
rue.
Voilà. Euh donc euh non, je suis je suis
inquiet d'abord, je suis inquiet parce
que la géopolitique mondiale, elle est
gravissime, je vous dis. On a un énorme
problème à régler en Europe. On a en
plus les métastases notamment au
Proche-Orient avec euh de plus en plus
un même théâtre stratégique. Le
Moyen-Orient et l'Europe, ça devient le
même théâtre stratégique. Le jour où
vous verrez arriver des missiles comme
il y a en Iran là de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée, ça va faire drôle. Ils ont
3000 missiles les Iraniens mais ils sont
l'équivalent en Europe n'existe pas.
Donc falloir qu'on se réveille, qu'on se
prépare à à vivre dans un monde très
très dangereux. Donc ça c'est déjà
difficile. Si en plus derrière on a un
pays qui est pas prêt mentalement ni
économiquement, ça va être très
compliqué.
On fait comment pour réarmer les esprits
pour faire rêver la population pour un
destin commun ?
Bah déjà, on lui rappelle ce que c'était
la France quoi. C'est un très très grand
pays, un très beau et très grand pays et
on est fier de notre histoire.
Je vous dis le problème c'est qu'elle
est inconnue. Beaucoup beaucoup de de la
jeune génération, surtout tous ceux qui
arrivent de l'extérieur, ils connaissent
pas. Le pire c'est qu'ils ont même pas
envie de connaître. Eux, ils sont dans
autre chose.
Ils sont dans quoi ?
Dans TikTok.
Ils sont dans les jeux vidéos.
Regardez, regardez les gens sur leur
téléphone. Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Bah,
ils font des ils postent des des trucs
insensés que moi je veux même pas
connaître. Mais mais en tout cas c'est
pas un échange d'idée quoi. Vous voyez
quel regard vous portez sur la Chine et
ses ambitions ?
Bah la Chine c'est la Chine. Moi, j'aime
beaucoup les Chinois. Ce sont des gens
qui ont le qui ont le le culte du
travail et de l'histoire, qui s'occupent
de leur famille. Ce sont des gens bien
les Chinois. Le problème c'est que ils
ont été très longtemps maltraités par
les puissances coloniales et que
maintenant ils veulent se venger et que
pour Jingping c'est le moment de la
Chine. Donc ce siècle va être celui de
la Chine et il se donne de tous les
moyens pour que la Chine reprenne le
contrôle, qu'elle devienne la première
puissance mondiale.
Donc les Chinois
et donc ça va ça va ça risque de
voilà, ils mettent leur poids euh ils
font des choses assez extraordinaires.
par exemple, aller de l'autre côté de la
Lune
et des choses très brutales comme
prendre le contrôle de la mer du Chine
en mettant beaucoup d'argent, beaucoup
de moyens, beaucoup d'hommes. La Chine
veut se venger, les Russes vont vouloir
se venger, les Ukrains vont vouloir se
venger,
les Européens courent comme un petit
canard sans tête, les Américains sont
quand même en perte d'influence
relative. Il reste toujours la monnaie
de réserve, même si elle représente plus
que 15 % de la richesse mondiale, c'est
qu'encore la monnaie de réserve, ils ont
encore la plus grande force militaire du
monde et ils ont la ils sont la force
d'innovation du monde. Donc ils sont pas
ils resteront une très grande puissance
même si relativement ce sera moins, ça
restera une très grande puissance. Mais
ce qui va changer, mais c'est c'est tout
ce que vous venez de dire, plus la
démographie. Sachez que en 40 % des
humains sera africains. Presque un
humain sur deux sera africain. Pourquoi
? Parce que la courbe démographique est
en train de chuter partout, y compris en
Chine et que le seul endroit où la
transition démographique n'est pas
encore faite, c'est en Afrique. Donc on
va avoir une montée de la de la la
pression démographique en Afrique
plus le réchauffement climatique.
Voilà, donc des vagues migratoires et on
est qu'au début des grandes vagues
migratoires d'étude. Et là, il faudra
vraiment que les Européens se disent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait.
Donc, on fait quoi ? fait un mur.
Il va falloir il va falloir faire des
murs et il va falloir mettre pas mal
d'argent aussi aux bons endroits en
Afrique pour que les des jobs puissent
être trouvés sur place parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de richesse en Afrique.
Par contre, il y a une très mauvaise
gouvernance. Donc quand vous êtes jeune,
si vous êtes un jeune malien par exemple
aujourd'hui euh vivant dans le nord du
pays où il y a que des épines et des
chèvres, si vous voulez vous marier, il
faut des chèvres.
Mais mais ce que je dis, je je le dis
sur le temps de la plaisanterie, mais il
se trouve que c'est pas du tout une
plaisanterie. Si vous vous êtes un
jeune,
des piles et des chèvres.
Non mais pour vous marier, il faut
offrir un troupeau de chèvre au père de
la mariée. Donc comment vous faites pour
offrir un troupeau de chèvre quand vous
quand vous êtes misérable, vous avez pas
été à l'école, bah il y a soit vous
partez, vous faites l'immigration, soit
soit vous résignez à votre sort, soit
vous entrez chez les djihadistes et il
vous donne une calache, une moto et vous
jouez au petit chef et là vous vous
installez. C'est c'est comme ça que ça
se passe. C'est c'est le vécu
en ce moment. Il y a Poutine qui
organise un forum avec les bricks.
Hm. À Casan. Oui.
Casan
c'est quoi la traduction de Casan ?
C'est le fourneau, le creuset de du
Tatarstone. Non, je me trompe,
c'est très beau. C'est c'est une partie
de de
cet univers russe et en Asie centrale
qui est magnifique.
Donc les bricks,
on fait quoi ? On continue de regarder
comme si c'était à BB. Vous avez deux
théories. Il y a la théorie majoritaire,
c'est que ça c'est pas grave parce que
c'est très hétérogène parce que tout le
monde s'entend pas, personne s'entend
là-dedans. C'est un c'est c'est le sel,
le poivre, tous les ingrédients
possibles. Mais tout ça ne fait pas tout
ça ne fait pas un système alternatif.
Moi dans mon lit, je défends la thèse
inverse. Je dis qu'en effet, tout le
monde est très hétérogène mais que ces
gens-là vont représenter 50 % de la
richesse mondiale dans 20 ans, 2050.
construire une alternative à Swift
à Swift mais pas seulement ils ont ils
sont en train de créer une banque de
développement qui est dirigée par Delma
Youssef qui est basé à à Shanghaiï euh
de plus en plus la monnaie de réserve
américaine elle est contournée parce
qu'ils veulent pas être soumis aux
sanctions. Sachez que 60 % des pays du
tir monde sont sous sanction
américaines. Donc les gens n'en peuvent
plus naturellement. Donc il contournent
les Iraniens ont 40 ans d'expérience
pour contourner les centrales, les les
sanctions américaines. Les Russes là,
ils ont contourné massivement avec
l'aide de qui ? Des Turcs, des Chinois
euh et toutes sortes de pays qui qui
leur vendent ce que ce dont ils ont
besoin en contournant et en passant par
d'autres monnaies. Euh et là, le Han est
en train de commencer à s'imposer ou
bien les cryptonnaies. Vous avez vu que
euh Poutine par exemple devient un
amateur de crypto parce qu'il a compris
que le cryptos peut contourner le
dollar. Donc on est en train d'assister
à la construction brique par brique,
c'est un mauvais jeu de mots, d'un
système
non pas alternatif mais mais qui qui
contourne la domination
de l'ordre américain de la prè de la
deuxème guerre mondiale. Moi, j'ai
comparé ça dans mon livre à l'histoire
d'une maison qui
engrenage aux éditions de Jacob. Voilà,
engrenage. Dans engrenage, décrit une
maison qui a été construite, une belle
maison sur une une falaise. Euh
simplement le climat a changé et la mer
est devenue de plus en plus brutale.
Donc elle érôe, elle casse la falaise,
elle casse la falaise jusqu'à ce que la
maison s'effondre. Et la question c'est
qui va reconstruire, qui va être
l'architecte et où est-ce qu'elle va
être reconstruite la maison ? On pose
une question avec votre grande
expérience
qui on va dire de nos élites de nos
intellectuels encore vivant
qui est est tout à fait en possession de
ses moyens pour comprendre la situation
et aider la France. Qu'est-ce qui nous
reste ? Donnez-moi cinq noms
comme comme un toello en
comme personne unello positif. Il y a
des gens de qualité mais qui ?
Bah je sais pas moi je
Bruno Le
qui voulait mettre la Russie à genou.
Non je je je pense qu'il y a il y a il y
a il y a plein de talents en France.
Bah alors donnez-mo 5
s'il y en a que s'il y en a plein.
Non
mais il y a il y a des
qui est suffisamment burné pour voir les
choses en face.
Bah moi quand je vais vous dire, je je
j'ai pas eu cette conversation avec
François Hollande récemment, mais comme
j'ai vu Nicolas,
essayer de le destituer non.
Oui. Oui. Parce qu'il avait foutu les
photos des raides des missions
militaires de devant les journalistes.
Faut quand même faut quand même le
faire.
Le président ne devrait pas dire ça.
Oui, il a mis toutes les photos de des
missions de guerre de la l'armée de
l'air sur la Syrie devant sous le nez
des journalistes.
Et quoi encore ?
Quelle est l'inconséquence ? Et quoi
encore ? Non, il y en a un qui a compris
euh parce que je parle assez
régulièrement avec lui, c'est Sarco. Il
il est parfaitement clair sur les grands
enjeux du monde. Il y a des gens qui ont
été éliminés comme François Fillon qui
sont mais François Fillon, il a été
éliminé pour voilà comme ce qui a été
tenté aux États-Unis contre Trump a
réussi en France contre Fillon à dégager
brutalement en 3 semaines. Aux
États-Unis, ça a pas marché. Trump est
toujours là.
Euh remarque incidente. Non, il y a des
gens qui ont une vraie expérience.
Bon, Sarco, il a quand même quelques
valoches, hein.
Oui, oui, bien sûr.
Ben des grosses.
Oui. Non, mais je dis pas, vous me
dites, est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui
sont conscients de ce qui se passe ?
Parmi ceux que je côtoie avec qui je
parle, c'est le cas.
Sarco Fillon, François Hollande,
je sais pas, peut-être. Peut-être.
Qui d'autre ? Deux autres.
M'embêtez.
à ce point-là, c'est le désert.
Non, mais
vous savez, si j'ai arrêté si j'ai
arrêté mon engagement politique en 2017,
c'est que j'en pouvais plus.
Mais vous en pouviez plus de cette bande
de tocar
égoïste qui était en train de découver
pas on arrivait pas à avancer sur
Il nous reste 12 minutes.
Ouais. J'avais pas envie d'être un petit
poids devant devant Macron. J'ai vu ce
que c'était que Macron dès l'époque.
J'avais pas envie de ça. J'avais j'avais
pas une âme de traître d'aller d'aller
faire comme d'autres rejoindre Macron.
Et j'avais pas une âme non plus de de
traite vis-à-vis de mes électeurs dans
ce quartier. Ils ont tous le bac, ils
sont tous sophistiqués. J'allais pas
leur dire dans des weekend prochain,
vous votez tous Macron et puis après le
coup suivant vous votez pour moi, je
serai dans l'opposition. Comment vous
comment vous vendez ça ? Comment vous
expliquez ça ? La vérité, c'est que il y
a plus de ligne idéologique. Il faut
avoir une ligne idéologique. C'est et
celle-là, elle est très simple. C'est la
nation, la fierté de la nation et la
reconstruction de notre pays de
l'intérieur. Il faut qu'on recommence à
fabriquer de la richesse en France, à
former les gens pour ça.
Sans énergie.
Sans énergie, sans commence comme sans
énergie. On est on a été les fonds,
mais on est les fondateurs. L'énergie,
vous parlez, moi j'allais vous parler
d'énergie nucléaire, c'est nous qui
avons su faire. On l'a laissé tomber. On
a cassé le jouet quand même. Les
l'énergie nucléaire française, c'est une
des hes absolues des 40 dernières
années. On avait la meilleure filière
nucléaire de la totale filière depuis
l'uranium jusqu'au retraitement du
plutonium. On savait faire des
centrales, on en sortait trois par an et
on a tout cassé. tout cassé parce que
les il tirait la bour parce que les
monsieurs machins s'entendaient pas avec
madame machin si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire.
Les Allemands essayer de nous la mettre
à l'envers quoi.
Les Allemands et alors les Allemands ils
ont décidé de se suicider en sortant du
nucléaire maintenant ils ouvrent des
centrales à charbon. C'est bravo. Bravo
l'écologie.
Non, on a on a vous savez
messager, ça a été le prix Nobel a été
donné à trois français en 1965
dont François dont François Jacob le
père de mon éditeur actuel.
Vous croyez qu' que la France a su
exploiter ça derrière et fabriquer l'ARN
messager ? Non, c'est les Américains
partir. Le le type qui a fait Moderna,
il travaillait chez Merieux, pourquoi il
est parti aux États-Unis ? aujourd'hui
milliardaire
et c'est ça le truc qu'on a pas, c'est
qu'on on sait pas on sait pas honorer
les gens qui qui réussissent bien.
Odile Jacob, c'est d'ailleurs une très
belle maison où il d'ailleurs ils nous
ont publié notre mentor Jacques Blamont
et et on remercie qu'il y a encore des
maisons d'édition comme ça. Il nous
reste 9 minutes. J'ai promis de vous
lâcher en tour et en heure.
Oui oui parce que je suis attendu. Euh
est-ce que vous avez un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec nous ? Je
voudrais ensuite trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté autre que
engrenage aux éditions Jacob. Donc trois
livres qui ont compté pour vous et
ensuite un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Vous avez 9 minutes
pour les jeunes générations. Je leur ai
dit avant un sujet qu'on a pas abordé.
un sujet qu'on a pas abordé. Bah, on n
pas abordé
la plongée sous-marine qui est une de
mes passions
qu'on a en commun
le Oui. et que et le sacage de la de la
terre, ça me ça me révulse.
Watson qui
l'agriculture intensive, les produits
chimiques dans la mer, la destruction
des espèces. Mais moi je le je le vois.
On le voit quand vous voyez moins
d'oiseaux, c'est quand il y a moins
d'oiseaux, c'est qu'il y a moins
d'insectes. Et s'il y a moins
d'insectes, c'est parce que ils ont
bourré les sols de pesticides. C'est une
catastrophe. Ça se déverse dans les
rivières, ça tue les poissons, ça arrive
dans la mer et après on va planter des
mas d'éolienne au milieu de tout ça et
après on s'étonne que les baleines
viennent s'échouer. Je veux dire c'est
une destruc. L'humain a cette capacité
de se de détruire qui était phénoménale.
Euh c'est une horreur,
c'est une impasse évolutive. On on et
quand il a fini de détruire la quand il
a fini de détruire la la la terre, il se
détruit entre eux. il est capable
d'inventer des bombes atomiques puis des
des armes biologiques. Des armes
biologiques
chimiques.
Chimique bien sûr, mais le pire ça va
être la les armes biologiques et quand
vous voyez ce qui est en train de se
passer avec l'intelligence artificielle,
la capacité l'intelligence artificielle
d'être utilisée dans les armes, donc
d'avoir des armes qui sont qui prennent
eux-mêmes les décisions de tir. Parce
qu'au bout d'un moment, si vous avez un
essin de drone, je sais pas quoi, qui se
parle entre eux, le conducteur derrière
humain, bah il va être rapidement
déborder. Donc on on rentre dans des
problématiques de destruction de cette
planète qui sont affolantes. Mais ça me
désespère moi qui qui aime tellement la
nature et la mer, ça c'est un sujet
majeur. Mais mais là encore, les hommes
Quel est votre plus beau souvenir de
plongeur ?
Euh la fois où j'ai failli être bouffé
par un requin marteau qui m'a qui m'a
qui m'a épargné. Euh non, j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de souvenirs. J'ai
j'étais avec Henry Germain Deelose qui
était le fondateur de la Commex et euh à
un moment euh à la fin de sa vie, il
était passionné de de d'épave, de
recherche d'épave et on cherchait des
épaves Ming euh dans le D3 de la Sondre
et on a trouvé une épave simplement la
marine indonésienne qui était avec nous
sur le bateau. Quand on est retourné en
France, ils ont pillé le de le début du
le haut du bateau, ils ont fait exploser
le reste. Donc c'est à la fois un beau
et un triste souvenir.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà croisé le
regard d'un dauphin ambassadeur ?
Ambassadeur ? Non. Mais j'ai nager avec
des avec des avec des avec des requins
et avec des dauphins. Oui.
Et pourquoi le le marteau, il a essayé
de vous c'était le grand ou le petit
marteau ?
Très grand. Il faisait 6 7 m de je pas
descendait à 50 55 m au large du Bellise
à l'air ou ou
et et tout d'un coup, on voit ce trucl
arriver. Enf, j'étais avec un un
Vous étiez pas narcosé à 60 m à votre
âge ? Non non non, mais j'étais beaucoup
beaucoup plus jeune et ce truc est
arrivé avec la gueule entrouverte. Il
nous a suivi jusqu'à la surface. Cétait
moi je souhaitais que l'autre soit
bouffé avant moi mais heureusement il a
bouffé personne. Mais c'était très
effrayant.
Trois livres conseillés à notre
communauté.
Moi, je leur dirai de lire Vassili
Grossman
parce que tout toute la Russie
toute la Russie est dans Vassili
Grossman.
l'histoire de la guerre, la
compréhension de ce que c'est que la
Russie. Babel, un autre ukrain russe,
lui venait d'OD, c'était un juif russe
qui raconte la première guerre mondiale,
la la cavalerie rouge, c'est
extraordinaire.
Euh les amortes de Gogol, génial. D'où
je vous parle de littérature russe parce
qu'elle est c'était le sujet
d'aujourd'hui, mais il y a plein de
plein d'autres livres merveilleux de
l'est d'Eden à Zola en passant. Moi,
j'ai beaucoup aimé Zola quand j'étais
quand j'étais gamin. J'avais tout lu de
et et puis puis Balzac et Victor Hugo.
Si vous voulez comprendre la France et
la Révolution française, faut lire 93.
Tout y est.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour la
la jeune génération ? La une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur internet.
Pour la jeune génération, je leur
diraiis de de faire ce qui les
passionne, de de vivre leur passion, de
de choisir quelque chose qui les
passionne et ils feront des grandes
choses sans se faire arrêter par les
obstacles parce que tout est difficile
surtout quand on est jeune, les portes
sont rarement ouvertes, elles sont plus
ouvertes aux États-Unis. C'est c'est
c'est beaucoup plus confortable et c'est
pour ça que c'est excitant l'Amérique
parce qu'on va pas vous demander votre
couleur de peau, votre origine, votre
religion, votre machin. Si vous avez
quelque chose, on va vous donner votre
chance et si vous cassez la gueule, on
vous redonne notre chance. Ça c'est
fantastique. C'est le modèle américain
que j'aimerais voir. Ça c'est le bon
côté américain que j'aimerais voir en
France plutôt que les hamburgers et
toutes les autres saloperies, les les
séries et toutes ces conneries qu'on
qu'on fait rentrer chez nous. Et et donc
le conseil c'est suivez votre passion.
S'il y a quelque chose qui vous
passionne dans la vie, il faut le faire.
Pierre Lelouche, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]